this story from axios Trump's 2025
Vision revealed I already really like it
because if you scroll down it says he's
vowing to get rid of marxist prosecutors
yeah
so uh I love how this is written as a
hit piece too yeah you're like yes this
is awesome this should be an in-kind
donation it's the best thing I've heard
ever he wants to kill the wall he wants
to give the president the authority to
hire and Fire Federal workers he wants
to reward schools that abolish tenure
for teachers it's the uh they say blah
blah blah blah he wants to defund the
justice department and FBI
he's boundary of marxist prosecutors he
wants a doj to investigate big Pharma
and Hospital networks he wants to use
the US military to go after drug cartels
and Street crime he wants to eliminate
an Obama era rule requiring cities and
local governments to address residential
segregation he wants Quantum Leap to
revolutionize the American Standard of
his Quantum Leap to revolutionize the
American standard of living includes
baby bonuses to create a new baby boom
and the design of 10 New Freedom cities
in the U.S he wants he wants National
concealed carry reciprocity
I'm like actually I was saying really
get me on board with Trump 2024. I love
it it's written as a hit piece too look
at this radical agenda meanwhile every
libertarian Conservative Republican is
like this is freaking awesome this is
just straight up good Trump well it's
all good Trump the idea that he would
use the military to go after Street
crime is a little is a little concerning
and all
insane because that's not what the
military is for I disagree I think
they're lying I I think what we've heard
from Trump is that the Insurrection act
should be used against riots and what
axios is doing is they're reframing it
to make it seem like he's talking about
a dude robbing a liquor store which
would be I believe a violation of Posse
Comitatus Trump was resistant to using
the military to even stop the riots I
think what he's saying now is hey if
this happens again we'll invoke the
Insurrection then I won't be too
critical since this is a news report
about what he said rather than just what
he said but the other thing that struck
me was that he wants to give the
executive Authority the right to higher
and Fire Federal Employees which could
be like some psycho could get into
office and fire everybody and put all
his sycophants in that's actually that's
good idea I immediately and that
schedule F's everyone yeah I love that
but but also I clicked the link and it
brings you right to his stop crime
restore safety and let me just read for
you it says the uh the the once our once
great Street cities are now controlled
by gangs cartels plagued to the mentally
ill and drug addicted homeless Trump
will Revitalize police departments and
reclaim safety dignity and peace for
law-abiding Americans who deliver record
funding to higher retained police
officers strengthen qualified immunity
and other protections for police
officers increase penalties for assault
on law enforcement put violent Defenders
and career criminals Behind Bars and
surge Federal prosecutors and the
National Guard into high crime
communities the only thing that remotely
comes close to using the military for
Street crime is National Guard and high
crime communities that's something we do
we we do the National Guard is deployed
in extreme circumstances if the bulk of
what he's saying is revitalizing police
departments for axios to frame it as he
wants to address Street crime with
military is a lie yeah hopefully he's
not talking about putting like the
National Guard on the south side of
Chicago standing on the street corners
with 8K I think he's talking about when
they deployed the National Guard to
Ferguson when there was widespread
riding and that was Obama who did that I
promise they won't have ak-47. you Evan
Ferguson protesting the streets and they
deployed the National Guard when you
have certain degrees of high crime they
deploy the National Guard into certain
areas it happens a lot depending on what
that crime is yeah and usually you got
to ask for it the state's got to ask for
it uh the federal government and it's
the state level anyway it's not
something the president does so with
that being said Ian I like that you're
skeptical about that yes it is good I I
was one of the few I'm still getting
about this when uh uh bukele and
then uh they did these big uh prison
camps for all these gang members I was
one of the few guys the conservatives
are still ripping me for this but it's
fine because I'm not going to change my
position I was one of these guys saying
ah you really sure about that we want to
round up like five six hundred thousand
people or whatever and throw them in
like a prison camp overall celebrating
like uh there's no more like pro cop you
know Pro let's crack down use broken
windows policing guy to me but you know
we have to be careful as conservatives
who support Liberty to not like be like
liberals like you're the current
thingers the current thing oh look
there's a guy down there in South
America who's cleaning up the streets
yeah well how did he do that like I can
clean up the streets too like I'll hire
a bunch of special forces guy to like
whack five six hundred bad guys the
streets are clean but like have we
considered the externalities of that so
I'm with you like I'm always skeptical
when I when I hear that and that's good
I agree but my question is at what point
are you at in a war or are you dealing
with a circumstance of uh uh uh Mark and
reprisal so with the issue of uh cartels
or like in El Salvador you have extra
governmental entities that become
governments at what point are you at War
well listen in his it's a fair it's a
fair question to ask at what point are
you at War I
the problem is who gets to declare that
then
right this is because you're asking a
good question but but my question is
another question
what happens if you get an Obama then
who says uh you know what we're at a
state of war and these conservatives uh
they're talking about a stolen election
that's all treason and you're all going
to go to jail so I would rather err on
the side of Extreme Caution and have
limits on the on the uh on the natural
vicissitudes of men's emotions than to
have this kind of Open Season attitude
and I find what people do is they get
desperate and Desperation you know
here's the thing I use this analogy on
my show a lot right you ever see The
Walking Dead before we woke I used to
loved that show then it went crazy and a
bunch of books or whatever there's that
that season where they go into prison
but to get away from the zombies and I
say to my audience all the time like who
the walks in a prison right locks the
door in because the prison is a bad
thing the answer is people who are
afraid of what's on the outside
um that's who does that oh look the
zombies on the outside are worse than us
taking away our own freedom in a prison
that's what worries me about
conservatives specifically you know I'm
not saying like championing what what
they did know Salvador is is a horrible
if it works out great fine and civil
liberties eventually are respected but
you've got to understand like this is
the kind of stuff that tyrants love they
love to scare you enough because their
fear is the coin of the realm right that
you'll crave this too oh man can we do
that here and then you get an Obama
Biden and you're the one in the freaking
handcuffs and you're like holy did
I sign up for this and that's what
happened with the Patriot Act
so the issue that I see is if principled
people are constantly going up against
unprincipled people the unprincipled
people will win people who are willing
to like I was talking about Monopoly
right if you're planning on someone
who's actively cheating and won't stop
but you keep playing anyway my question
is I I like what El Salvador is doing I
don't know the I'm not going to say I
know every single detail on every single
thing they've done but they when I think
like three months without any murders
since it started rounding up the
criminal cartels you've got a bunch of
people who are actively in these so so
I'll let's reframe this into the United
States the left wants to release people
from jail
they're saying you know this guy was a
shoplifter let's release him what does
he do he goes right out right away and
shoplifts again gets caught and starts
laughing saying y'all caught me the
first time and let me go
it's very difficult to know how we deal
with problems like this at scale when a
country is a lot smaller there's a lot
less people we're very very libertarian
but the bigger issue at play was a
shared sense of community where most
people shared a religious values and
there was a lot less people when militia
meant the local men who would take up
arms to defend their Community now you
have a place like New York City where
people don't even know who lives next
door to them and so what happens is you
get a guy on a train threatening people
everybody just puts their head down and
ignores it no one's doing anything so
I'll put it this way the the solution to
this problem
in the most extreme circumstances may be
the Insurrection act sending out the
National Guard or the Army to stop Mass
unrest in the United States the real
solution is shared moral Frameworks
which we don't have and rebuilding that
takes generations and so it's been
destroyed and dismantled over the past
couple Generations
it may come to a point where you've got
a left that is saying abortion up to
nine months no questions and we've had
these people on this show say that
outright yes and I'm like that's crazy
to me and here I am traditionally in the
Democrat Camp of pro-choice meaning in
the first trimester or the first six to
ten weeks or 12 weeks or 15 weeks we'll
find that number even Trump said
something like that conservative saying
no no we're pro-life no abortion no
matter what yet I am more aligned with
conservatives in that we all recognize
taking the life of a baby that is
completely capable of serving on its own
makes no sense that's just insane so
what happens when you have a state like
Colorado where they're actively aborting
I'm doing air quotes here babies at the
point of birth because it's legally
allowed should the federal government go
in and start arresting these doctors and
Prosecuting them at what point do you
then have the left saying you are the
authoritarian fascist arresting medical
professionals and they frame it the way
they want
I think it's time for us to um
give a big double barrel you to the
left um pardon the language here folks
uh why do we give a about what the
left is saying so you're telling me that
the side recommending genital mutilation
uh saying we should put kids in
schools and inner cities for Generations
that have no chance of prosperity the
side that won't pay a freaking dime in
extra taxes themselves that demands a
sit on their fat asses and do nothing
all day while you support them through
your meritocratic work that we should
take them seriously when oh look you
guys are the fascist because there's an
infant child that does nothing that's
nothing wrong we're not going to suck
its brains out and you want to do
something to stop I don't really give a
what the left says so I I don't I'm
not suggesting you do I'm just saying
like if you want cutesy time and stuff
like I'm definitely not your guy because
I give zero this is the point when
do you send the federal law enforcement
to go arrest them on Colorado see that's
different that's different that's a
different argument because there is an
option there like if we're talking about
you can't transfer the abortion argument
over to that because we're talking about
like sucking out a kid's brains in a
post-birth abortion or we're talking
about crime and law enforcement like we
have an option why I live through it in
New York City so before we send in the
National Guard and talk about any
military intervention we could just do
like what we actually did in New York it
was called broken windows policing
wasn't even complicated they just went
out I mean we don't have time to go over
the whole thing here but the essence of
it is really really simple they went out
and said hey we should just arrest
people for doing like crimes like it
can't be that simple no I promise you it
was when I got out of the police
department the whole idea was listen we
need cops on the corner so if you you
see a kid jumping a turnstile on the
train station let him go Tim because you
know what I need you out there I can't
have you processing this kid all night
that's not a dumb idea you're like yeah
that makes sense we want to prevent the
robberies he's in a rape's not that well
what happened the dude who jumped the
turnstiles the guy who rapes the woman
he hasn't paid a fare but so you catch
him there and they cleaned up New York
overnight this is my point
when Trump gets elected do we send in 2
000 agents to start arresting all of the
doctors all of them they all have to be
arrested because they're all
facilitating abortion to the point of
birth if you are killing an infant child
in violation of the law then I'm really
sorry but you made that decision so in
El Salvador when you've got 10 15
000 guys in one area who are all
obviously displaying tattoos working as
guards actively participating in in
seditious actions yeah then they send in
the government they arrest them all and
the problem is when we get these photos
of all these gang members being arrested
and you get people of good principles
saying like I'm kind of worried about a
government going and rounding all these
people up
now people in El Salvador I met a guy in
DC from El Salvador and uh so he was
talking to another guy I heard him
mention something about I said are you
from El Salvador says yes and I said
what do you think about what's going on
and he says I left there a long time ago
but now it's getting really really good
and I'm gonna go back thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time